now we can speak now to the security
minister damian hines mr heinz very good
morning
good morning neil we have just heard uh
that took place the night before the
duke of edinburgh's funeral i'm
wondering would you on behalf of the
government wish to apologize to the
queen this morning
neil i i mean like everybody i think
who's read this story this morning like
you as well i was shocked
i was shocked to read to read it i have
only just read it it's just out in this
morning's
papers and we will have to see what
uh
what what what comes out further in in
in the investigation this is a
particularly somber time of course for
our for our whole country the whole
nation shared
with her majesty in her morning and
as was just been said in your piece
there i think
what one of the uh i mean
everybody was so struck
by that picture the the ultimate and
exceptional dignity of her majesty yet
at prince philip's funeral and
we will have to see what we will have to
see what comes out
in the investigations this will be part
of the
the investigations taken on by by sue
gray and and we must wait to see what
comes through in that
sure but i mean it clearly wasn't a
somber atmosphere inside downing street
the night before again i'll reiterate
the prince phillips funeral there was a
suitcase full of booze there was music
there was dancing
downing street has not denied any of
these details can you and i both just
accept the fact that on the face of it
what took place that night was a party
and it shouldn't have happened
so i
as i say i mean i'm shocked to read
these the these allegations and
um
as you rightly say particularly at that
at that time but it is it is a story
that's just come out in the
in the press this morning i i i honestly
don't
know more about it clearly i i wasn't
there and i don't know
um you know firsthand on the basis
sorry minister but on the basis that
downing street has not challenged any of
the detail on the basis that they have
not challenged the detail of it on that
basis this was a party it shouldn't have
happened
so i look i i totally accept that
if the details that are in the story
turn out to be true then
that would be
i mean
clearly people will people are going to
form their their judgment but
it will be part of these broader uh
investigations being undertaken by by by
sue gray the terms of reference have
been clear that those investigations
should cover
i should cover
events plural alleged events the nature
of them who attended them what the
purpose of them was
and and i think we we do need to see
what comes through what comes through in
in that report promise has also been
clear the terms of reference are clear
that if you know
if allegations are found to be true if
individuals appear to um have been uh
guilty of wrongdoing then action can
indeed be taken
the the line from number 10 is that the
prime minister wasn't there i'm just
wondering in in what world it matters
whether or not the prime minister
attended the events the night before at
the duke of edinburgh's funeral we know
that when he has attended those events
in the past in what we have been told
repeatedly is his house his back garden
he didn't bring it to a halt so given
the fact that we know some incredibly
senior figures in downing street were at
this particular party you're certainly
not suggesting that there would have
been an event like that if any one of
them had had any doubt in their mind
about whether or not the prime minister
would have approved
so
neil i'm i'm i'm not suggesting and and
anything i mean because look i as i said
i i don't know the detail of
of of those alleged events or or indeed
more broadly that's why we have that's
why we have the investigation uh going
on into uh you know in into the series
of of different allegations and
different
uh different happenings and i do think
it's important that this story has just
come out uh it's just come out this
morning i think we do need to wait to
see
what goes on um what comes out of that
report the prime minister
made his apology on wednesday i think a
a a a sincere and and heartfelt apology
in the context of course of the
knowledge that all of us have
of the very severe privations um that
the whole country has
has had as a result of the coronavirus
restrictions in some in some cases
people being unable to to mourn their
loved ones or to be with to be with them
at the last so these are incredibly um
important important matters and i do
think it's right
that the time is given
for for those for those investigations
to run that to run their proper course
and then if action needs to be taken
against individuals it can be i i was a
minister i'll say something this morning
that i really do with politicians i've
got a degree of sympathy for you you've
been the government minister that has
been sent out this morning having
received an absolute hospital pass yet
again from staff working inside number
10. i mean andrew but the problem is is
all of this raises questions about the
prime minister's suitability to be prime
minister andrew bridgen the prime
minister's position has become untenable
leadership is not just about the job
title or even making big decisions it is
equally about having a moral compass of
knowing not just right from left but
right from wrong i mean few including mr
bridgen would have expected him to be
the moral compass at the heart of the
government at the moment but he's got a
point
well i think leadership is incredibly uh
important and i am entirely behind the
prime minister and the government and i
think the leadership that
the the prime minister has shown
particularly through through through the
coronavirus um has been has been very
strong we are
we've had the strongest vaccination
program in europe most tested
uh nations in all of this we know all of
this but we're talking we're talking
about
we're talking about a party at which a
suitcase full of brews was brought in a
party at which drunkenly or otherwise
the sun the prime minister's sons swing
was broken by one of those attending
dancing drinking it was a party and all
of this the night before the duke of
edinburgh's funeral the the night before
when the queen herself will have been
busy preparing for one of the most
solemn sad days of her life she sat
alone in the charcoal i mean
these are all significant questions
about the prime minister's
competence surely
well as as you say this was a
particularly
particularly somber
moment
and
all that you say about the the response
the reaction that people will have to to
hearing this story i totally understand
i myself am shocked to read
to read these allegations um this
morning but i but i'm i'm just not in a
position to be able to comment
uh
further on them it's not that i'm it's
not that i'm keeping something from you
neil i mean i i don't know because i
wasn't there and and it is important
that we don't just operate off a
often used story uh that's not to
diminish the importance of uh of of
media which is incredibly important but
we don't work just off one new story the
story stories
we have
yes there have been there have been many
there have been many news stories and i
think that's i think that further
highlights why
it's important that we're able in a
deliberative democracy to have a senior
civil servant
somebody with a great integrity and
respect across the political
spectrum look at all of these things in
the round
and to and to make to make an assessment
in the round
those findings then obviously
will become public and then there'll be
an opportunity in parliament pm's
already said he will then
come and make a statement that means
then you know followed by questions and
and scrutiny from members of parliament
and then of course
uh scrutiny from you and and your
colleagues in the media and i think it
is important that we that that process
um can run its course well we we await
the the findings of the investigation
into the prime minister by someone
appointed by the prime minister with
great interest i do whatever i want to
dwell just for a second on on on your
briefing the revelations yesterday that
a very significant
figure within the labour party has come
perilously close to what it appears as a
you know a
a member of the chinese intelligence
apparatus are there any concerns in your
mind about the probity of barry gardner
no i mean neil this isn't just this
isn't a story about one british
politician or even one political party
this is a story
an incident an item
about
how
um other states can seek to
concede to influence um
our country in different ways one of
which is is political
is political interference and one of the
ways of doing that is through
is through provision of finance and of
course that's a concern but
i mean what came out yesterday i mean
this is an example of our system working
this is our world leading intelligence
and security services
discovering this and and and finding a
way to to to to disrupt it so as i say
it's an example of a system at work
i i suppose the prime minister of course
under a huge amount of pressure this
morning he can at least console himself
with the fact that he is not prince
andrew what do you make of the decision
taken by buckingham palace to strip him
of his military roles and indeed of his
hrh title
well these these are matters for um
for the crown matters for the palace and
i know obviously
matters in which they will
um consider exceptionally exceptionally
careful now i don't think it's right for
for me to comment
damian hines great to have you on the
programme this morning really do
appreciate it
thank you